[Applause]
an Obama and the director of the Center
for climate health and the global
environment at Harvard Gina McCarthy is
back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well as someone whose job had been the
number one protector of our environment
these must be very trying days for you I
mean in trying days for anyone who picks
up the paper I don't see a headline but
a week goes by that isn't like more
alarming than even ones a couple of
years ago first it was the insect
apocalypse all the insects are dying
last week it was the birds we're killing
I think a third of all the birds in
North America are you doing this just to
depress me I am I'm doing it well I I
want to answer I yesterday there was
about the oceans we've made a spit sink
out of the oceans and we can't live on
this planet without the oceans I just
want to know give it to me straight doc
is it too late because I know they
wouldn't tell us if it was because we
I've had I've read quotes from like
James Hansen he said in 2006 we have to
in the next ten years decrease the rate
growth rate of co2 if that doesn't
happen within ten years we're gonna pass
these tipping points Al Gore
Inconvenient Truth the world will reach
the point of no return if drastic
measures weren't taken to reduce
greenhouse gases by 2016
I see we passed four point four hundred
and fifteen parts per million of carbon
dioxide I remember when they said you
can't pass 400 so what say you well what
I say is that we have a big challenge
ahead but it's not too late and I say to
you that we have to work together
I can't by myself tell you that we're
not past tipping points but if you can't
do something about this [ __ ] let's stop
worrying about it let's just do what we
can do there are so many things that we
can do
[Applause]
I read al gore's op-ed in the New York
Times last Sunday and you know I didn't
realize we actually are so close
we're so close that some of the things
he points out as recently as 2014
electricity from solar and wind was
cheaper only in about 1% of the world
five years later these are the cheapest
sources in two-thirds of the world we
actually are not that far away Germany
gets all of his electricity down from
renewable until you asked me about how
do I feel now there's all kinds of
rollback said EPA going on and I get
that but there's two things that that
you know really I keep telling myself
every morning one is that they're not
particularly good at governing so they
stink at rollbacks they have an 8%
approval rating in the courts so we're
doing pretty good oh and and the other
thing is everything we read about that
they try to do oh yeah they do a lot of
announcements well but you're saying
it's not happening no because well and
I'm saying do is come to a specific
outcome contrary to law and science and
when it gets to the courts they don't
tend to appreciate that right but the
you know but the other thing is that
we've got to stop focusing everything we
think about on climate or other things
about what Trump is or isn't doing or
what his administration is doing let's
talk about what's really going on in the
real world you mentioned that clean
energy is going gang-bangers because
it's cheaper it's better cleaner
oh that's too
gangbusters you're right blame it on me
mr. potty mouth it's it's infectious
let's start that over again yeah a lot
of good things happen
[Applause]
Greta turn Berg you're at the UN climate
I mean yeah you know about this young
lady from Sweden she's a teenager she
sailed across the ocean so what I mean
this was this is already I think become
iconic but I want to show it tonight you
have stolen my dreams in my childhood
with your empty words yet I'm one of the
lucky ones people are suffering people
are dying
entire ecosystems are collapsing we are
in the beginning of a mass extinction
and all you can talk about is the money
in fairy tales of eternal economic
growth this is because this week kids
all over the world went on a a climate
strike apparently they're pissed off
that we've robbed them of their entire
future and killed the planet yeah
they're so picky the kids but it reminds
me a little of the Vietnam protests when
I was young because they have skin in
the game
unlike other generations they really
feel it and they see it and they know
Christ what the world what is the world
gonna be like when I'm 40 is a feel
right now that we're that we have
reached a tipping point we're not gonna
tolerate it anymore right and we
recognize that we have a moral response
[Applause]
you